I said I'm only come how you guys doing
and you came eating some wonderful
wonderful amazing people I just met mine
and he's been Muslim 20 years and we
want to know what amazed him so much
pulled him in to accept this beautiful
way of life and keep with it for over 20
years
awesome art how are you brother mm mm
fine feeling really good spiritually i
hamdulillah so tell us what pulled you
and what amazed you about Islam that had
you accepted you know it's very strange
with me I didn't know anything about
Islam
but I used to live the high life you
know going out is this this enjoy myself
something like Suraj
so one day after I came back from a big
I used to be a coach football coach
rugby and I came back from one of our
dinners and I was still feeling we had a
wonderful evening I was still feeling
down empty then I thought the Muslim
there must be more to life than this
this was a Saturday night so the next
morning I just laid in bed and I just
said okay if there's a god I want to
meet you if you want to meet me
let's get together I said to him but I'm
not going in the church because I used
to drink too much and I was conscious
that I might be smelling of alcohol so I
left it then my life started to change
it was amazing what happened I didn't
want to go into poverty more I didn't
want to do anything then one day some
boys came and they talked to me
and after they got out of me that Jesus
is the Son of God I just decided I'm
gonna be a Muslim so I just they said
you got to be about to take about they
didn't know about this I just took about
walk down to the mosque after a few
times you know you have what do you say
you are reticent but from about 6
o'clock away they kept telling me come
on do it do it then I took the Shahada
and I tell you something it's the best
thing I have ever done in my life
and if you really want to have a joyous
life it is contented its content it
because you know what's wrong and you
know what's right and if you apply it in
your life you're gonna have fun the
Prophet says contentment is in the heart
it's not money that's my story of coming
to Islam but I came to Islam they told
me about this man because it's a
Jamaican like myself I said they said he
got up in the morning 5 o'clock to pray
I says no chance nobody prays at 5
o'clock if I ever see this Suraj I'm
gonna tellin ya so you would never know
what Allah did Suraj Raj came all the
way from America because of a program to
Oldham to here yeah we're right yeah and
sit in a circle while we're eating I
could not believe it and then I told him
as a Suraj when I first saw you and he
were talking about this getting up early
I didn't notice Padgett then I thought
what a schemer it is what a guy so now
what you what can you tell is right I
now get up at 5 o'clock that prefect now
you took the Shahada justify made the
declaration there's nothing worthy of
worship Muhammad is the messenger yeah
like Jesus mosey but you don't aim to
say message yeah purpose of life you
worship the Creator not the creation you
start living it yeah you're now in it
twenty years you haven't given up no no
it's getting stronger getting strong why
because you're implementing it up that's
the biggest that's the videos that are
implemented you got implemented you know
if you get the recipe for a cake if you
don't make the cake you can't get the
joy that's it right so you can't take
the Shahada yeah and then skip
everything else we just go through the
ritual no and just not really have the
essence of it you know it's supposed to
have best thing take out one or two
virtues say it Allah loves kindness and
love is one of the greatest virtue just
start being kind to people and you will
see how your life just changed you just
start feeling fresh and beautiful now
from that example because I call
kindness it's a coin kindness to me is
like a money because allah subhanaw
taala says you know when you die you
can't take our paper money back or you
can't take the coins back but you take
back the kindness the things that you've
done to people so I spend kindness yeah
I use it as a coin so like I solve a
[ __ ] deal that air pacer was destitute
and something went on between he and I
and you know nice I don't want to give
you this tour the full story because
I'll be giving away certain things and I
ended up giving him some money I gave
him some money for Allah to feel good
yeah because I'm doing one of his virtue
kindness but he says is the most kind
that's implemented take with that run
with that thank you so much for sharing
that story with us hope you guys got the
benefit from the UK Manchester we'll see
you next time peace with you so long
they go